[Music]
foreign
like I would imagine well I'm surprised
you're not fat like Ben like Beignets
are you serious if I lived in New
Orleans and had Beignets and strip Po
Boys I've never even had one but I just
see it and it just looks used to be a
place in Boulder baby formula too
actually on there baby formula you see a
lot of the sisters bringing baby formula
outside of the French Quarter
it just can't enough
that's true man a couple of sisters out
there kidding up it's uh
you know it's weird you're talking about
this because I think that
like my best eating period you know you
start off skinny you work out in high
school you play football you know I had
a friend that used to eat a box of
[__] cereal for breakfast and then
Demon's cake oh how the [__] that in a
gallon of milk okay whatever the [__]
the milk is with the cereal was he
driving trucks no he was in high school
he lift weights and and then you know I
was eating too I had a great appetite
tonight
I moved to Colorado and they were they
took away the night eating there's no
more drinking and going to eat when I
was used to eating right it was an open
steak sandwich at two in the morning
with a filling cream of turkey soup and
not even brushing your teeth [__] just
going to bed with dirty teeth yes and
that's how I do it [__] yeah [__] up
so that's yeah that's where I'm from at
a place you could have been with dirty
you get dirty teeth and you you know you
don't uh I don't eat here at night I go
home if I'm really high I'll eat
whatever my wife cooked which is
controlled it's like a chicken cutlet
you know what I'm saying like it's not
like 20 chicken salads well there's 20
chicken cutlets you can [__] [__] UPS
they'll be like one leftover chicken
I'll eat a chicken color eat an apple
you know what I'm saying just it's crazy
I've been lucky all week my mom has been
here for almost a week no and I haven't
eaten this good in four years she's just
making breakfast she hasn't met we've
she we've been sleeping a little late we
had a couple days she made breakfast but
it's been like she made brisket she made
uh a couple kinds of different kinds of
chicken and it just oh I like all of
that stacked all my like my entire
fridge is full now for like I like peach
cobbler oh she made icebox cake have you
ever had that all you do is you you take
a layer of graham crackers and you have
to get the the cook and serve pudding
not like putting cups but they have to
cook pudding and you just do layers of
pudding and graham cracker you put in
the fridge and let it freeze up and then
put some whipped cream on it listen if I
went to a concert do you think I'm
bringing a hamster home with [__]
crazy I know I'm not no I'm not I'm
about to ride I'm gonna be [__] up the
whole night with this hamster but when
you leave when you leave Coco when you
leave the place that's when we get you
bro you get it there hey people are
leaving on access appeals they're on
Molly you leave you get that [__]
hams you get that warm little piece of
God in their hands they buy it every
time bro I was on the Rogan podcast and
I told the truth my main Apple trade if
anybody ever [__] with you come to me
yeah don't say nothing to him
you come to me and you go this guy
[__] me and this this this this and
this and this way and I'll ask you a
bunch of questions
and we'll then we'll lay a road plan for
you to torture this guy bit slap him
shoot him
just [__] with them buy this house on
fire you know steal his mail whatever
the [__]
first like I was when I was a kid I
really was the best like if you [__] a
man just wait and Rob your house
I would steal eight ball cash jewelry
but if I knew they loved their sneakers
I'm taking the sneakers too so when you
see them they're like man somebody
busted into my house and took my
sneakers they took my mother's jewelry
she just steal their spoons bro
everything anything that I knew would
get them I'm a professional torture and
when I got to Boulder in 87 I got the
molding got the boulder in uh December
Colorado six yeah I was running from
cops and drug dealers I owed like 60 000
in cash so you went to Boulder I was in
Aspen I was an aspen [__] causing
damage
86 oh please please you have no idea
Doug I was International you understand
sum up and asked me and I [__] up
the girl I'm with from Boulder we had
all I had already a Warren in Boulder
and I'm like let's take a chance let's
move back to bold like I pulled over no
warrant but I got arrested for [__]
reefer it doesn't really matter the the
whole story is I got a job the week
before [__] Denver gets beat up by
the Giants in the Super Bowl like that
[__] Thursday I started the job and
uh
rock and roll and we'll lock the door
and make bets to see how long it take
before Lee comes from shooting out the
window oh we locked a fit we locked this
dog this big girl in our town we like
this big girl one time we eat some acid
and we locked this big girl into a room
at this party and uh and we kept going
in there with [__] pots of [__]
warm water [__] pouring it on I feel
bad I feel horrible dude I didn't look
we was kids and we're on ass and dude
and then bro you can't tell me this
though and I'm straight you gotta tell
me how mushrooms you blocked the girl I
just remember how old were you I just
remembered probably 16.
let's say I was 14. that way it makes it
sound nice
but look she already
bruh
I was doing what happened was and we
kept going in the room with like these
pots of warm I don't know why we had the
pots of warm water because I think they
just were [__] up dude
but not like torches well she wasn't in
a cage enough she was just you know free
range in this room right I think she was
scared to come out and one time we went
in bro we heard this loud sound and we
went in and she she had ran against one
of the walls so hard bro I had [__]
moved the entire wall in this house dude
huge girl about two 240 pounds beautiful
girl too the most beautiful biggest girl
that I've ever known
uh beautiful girl beautiful hair
beautiful face large just large and
beautiful but she [__] got lifted bro
and uh
yeah man [__] I just came down a little
bit off that [__] I just had a little
mushroom [__] high [__] yeah so I
guess what are you talking about this
job oh yeah I'm making dick for wages
and they put me as a shagger
it's a body shop
combination detail shop uh-huh
[Laughter]
they made me a shag which means I
cleaned bathrooms I take garbage out I
pick up customers you know and it was
175 a week for like 90 [__] hours
like I I was the first one there I had
to be there at seven the thing opened at
8 30 or 8. I had to be that seven to
[__] sweep and 175 a week for 175 a
week I'll [__] clean off all the cars
start them all up warm them bring them
into the body shop according to order
numbers I think the whole thing man and
I liked it listen I was [__] up for a
long time this was a great little job
for me but you know what man 175 for all
these hours these [__] are
getting a little fat off me and I'm like
[__] it I want to go into detail shops I
started petitioning to go into detail
shop I was a really good [__] shagger
so they knew my work ethic the guy was
from [__] New York State Steve
something
there's so many [__] Steves in my
life that every time I look up his name
and [__] Facebook but he was good to
me Steve in fact Steve was the dude who
introduced me to Stephen Tidwell the
dude who I kidnapped Ken Vela with so
like that's how I knew all these guys so
I petitioned Steve I go Steve That's it
man I'm a great shag I want the [__]
job in the back you know I'm sick and
tired of making 175. yeah I want to make
200 bucks a [__] day like these
[__] good oops Yeah so one of the
guys heard me and he didn't like me
his name was Dirk something uh
Dirk wasn't a tough guy but he was one
of these guys that would fight me to the
end
but and he had the body shop guys he had
the the whatever guys the
the the
detailers they were on his side the
detailers were kind of a little [__]
right you know I knew like two of them
that were really cool
the other two were hunting because they
were above you yeah he was a supervisor
it's hierarchy so I said how am I gonna
get this [__] I see a dead rat
in a corner and I took it and I put in
his jacket pocket that's old school I
put in this jacket pocket the next
morning this guy comes in with a dent in
his car and the jacket holding on to it
he drove home all night with the mouse
in his pocket
and then the next morning he [__]
started this car racing for a pack of
cigarettes and
he crashed the car he [__] got
[Laughter]
is [__] up for you people are not
watching this dude uh I remember one
time we uh this uh
[Laughter]
that he was describing the girl I was
dating to me he was a father and he goes
thank God you got her off me he goes
when she was a kid I used to call a
dollar today
[Laughter]
[Music]
give me a dollar give me a dollar give
me how many [__] dollars yeah how
many [__] dollars do you need in a
day it was dollar death
dude I remember this
yeah now I feel bad about what we did to
that bigger girl bro okay you can't
break for you know but we didn't do it
because she was big we just did it she
just wanted to she just got [__] up
and she couldn't get out the room you
know like I got [__] one of my best
friends got [__] up one time and he
started talking about Asian people we
never even seen any Asians in our life
and he started your life no and I guess
maybe like in her past life he might
have known some Asians you know and so
he starts bringing up their names bro
and knowing them and knowing [__] about
him on this mattress in this house and
I'm like [__] dude you're [__] up bro
I'm leaving right so apparently I'm the
kind of friend that when your friend is
at his worst you [__] leave bro
because I was just talking about Chinese
people oh yeah well I've never met
Chinese men we've never known any what
is he saying he's just saying like hey
you remember [__] like sin like you
remember [__] son lamb bro he was
there for us you know and all this [__]
bro we don't know him dude you know he
was [__] like talking about Dorothy
Dorothy Dorothy you know we didn't know
any Asians bro and I'm like
no we live in a small town dude I mean I
remember population uh we probably had
about 2 000 growing up oh [__] this one
dude I remember was trying to be an
Elvis in person that he said he was an
Elvis impersonated right but he was just
a [__] alcoholic you know what I'm
saying like we don't need any Elvis bruh
you know we got 2 000 people we need
[__] gas money and we need drugs yeah
we need ideas bro give us some [__]
those [__] Elvis impersonators are a
pain in the ass
they really are get a [__] life I
gotta tell you something you know I told
Lee before when I first got into comedy
when I got serious about it in 94 there
was a guy in Denver
who you should go to Tommy works and I
know his haircut looked familiar like
when you look at somebody like hey looks
familiar but who am I I'm on coke pills
you know I'm biggie badass I'm eating
bad I got terrible habits who why the
[__] am I with somebody's hair kind of
[__] terrible and all of a sudden I
got a call from the guy he goes hey I'm
doing a gig
uh
uh dog in those days are 50 bucks you
know I'm like yeah I'll be there now and
I show up and he comes to the door and
he's got away 350 and he's got the belt
on the whole Elvis suit
you know I mean the guy is did you know
that was gonna be like that no yeah I
knew the whole time I was at home
preparing for this [__] when I walk in
the [__] door there he is [__]
bigger than life and I don't know when
they surprise you but he's like I'm the
elephant person I just do 10 minutes in
front of me
and you know what I think I was supposed
to get 50 bucks he gave me a yardstick
wow and then he calls me three months
later he goes hey I opened up a bar
hilarious so I get to this bar it's
Wednesday nights he's the main act and
he brings up three Comedians and at the
end he sings all those Elvis songs and
he's [__] horrible yeah I mean he's
[__] horrible he's smoking cigarettes
his teeth are green yeah they're
horrible he's [__] fat he had let
himself go but it sounds like Elvis
sounds like no voice but you know what
this guy did he was an Elvis
impersonator and someone that was his
claim to fame I mean the whole inside of
the club was Elvis themed right but it
had a wall of write-ups about him you
know all the awards he wanted and [__]
he was a Vegas boy and he was no good
maybe at some point I mean you know at
this point and he uh
he [__] uh bought this club they
bought him out
in Vegas like they bought them out
because his voice is so bad I don't
[__] know and he went to Colorado and
opened up a [__] little bar like it
wasn't even a bar guy it was like a
whole like a an old Boutique that he
turned into a bar during the week and
he's saying Elvis it was a woman's
closet hysterical hysterical but you
know what man
whatever the guy said he would always
pay me pay me double wow he never tried
to stick a finger up my ass he never did
drugs or nothing but he always bought me
a drink he'd go take a drink you know
don't I he goes I'm not gonna give you
two because I'm not gonna be responsible
for you driving right even if you have
money I don't want you to drink in here
go drink next door yeah
but he was solid like he liked me as a
comic and he always paid me and he
didn't blow smoke up my ass it's not
like he was going to make a video and
take me to Vegas thinking back and I
forgot his name and I'm really sorry
good dude he was just a terrible Elvis
yeah
no I think if Elvis came back to life
he'd shoot half these in person like
that's hell for Elvis like that's it
that's a great movie Elvis comes back
and kills all here
that's it all the bad ones of the maker
instead of Isis coming in and shooting
everybody it's a fat Elvis with a
missing leg and he's decapitated neck
and [__] he shoots people he goes to the
kitchen he takes something he leaves and
[__] and the cops don't mess with him
because it's Elvis
and he wasn't like he had no work they
let him dress up like they dress him up
like Santa around Christmas let him wave
at the trains and [__] coming into town
you know like seasonal greeter you know
and uh and he'd always like
like you'd see him and he'd be like oh
you know it's like get all the [__] out
of the break yeah just it's just us
you're an alcohol yeah you know [__]
Elvis in person you're not even in
uniform you're in an alley right now and
uh his kids he made him be Pentecostal
he had four kids no Mom he made him be
Pentecostals kept him in the yard
it just means they wear like big clothes
and believing like God like I think a
lot
you know but they wear like just huge
clothes like cheap clothes like they
look like like the kids look like rodeo
clowns you know like they just look
you know like and it the girl let me
feel her breasts actually one time
through the bar they had a barbed wire
fence around their house the girl let me
feel some [__] titty ah [__] uh
what was her name
right
[Laughter]
ah this song you see [__] tuna and
ice cream every day and vomit on the bus
dude so people would [__] beat him up
wait a second we'll eat the vamp we'll
eat the tuna first of the ice cream I
don't know he started with both of them
already in them and people would [__]
beat him but he'd already be sick
he'd already be sick dude in the [__]
dead
uh made the kid a wooden shirt one year
for [__] Christmas dude made him a
[__] shirt out of wood I'm coming up
from church
it's Wednesday
they're in the garage
I swear to god dude like cool or was it
just like a big box that he did it was
horrible I mean at the time it was cool
you know at the time it was I mean it
was kind of beautiful the kid like cried
and [__] when he when he put him in it I
couldn't have been at home right now
watching Empire jumping up and down with
black people yeah [__] donuts and
[__] and you're over here telling me
this crazy [__] who else eats a mushroom
on a Wednesday I'm sitting here going to
watch us dude what is wrong with me I
should know better but I don't give a
[__] anymore to the point in my life
where you know what
I look at my draw and I got Quaaludes in
there I got [__] grenades
baby pacifiers I gotta do all this [__]
that's in there baby pacifiers but those
are for you oh
you know you look at all this mushrooms
and you go on the road and you're like
what the [__] people actually doing this
[__] every night and I'm sitting you
know yeah but my friends today where
they were excited like you're going on
[__] you're going with mad flavor
dude we're gonna tune in you know I mean
so I think that that
you know we're getting to live some of
the dream that other people don't get to
live you know when you're sitting at
home and you know you probably sit next
to your wife or your husband
um or you know somebody you might not
even [__] maybe you do love them
still but who knows you know you need a
little [__] speed bump you know
but yeah that dude made his son a wooden
shirt and then some kids spray painted
schwa stickers on it man [__]
you can't wash your shirt oh yeah they
spray painted swastikas on the wood but
no we never we didn't have any Jews
either we didn't have anybody you know
people just seen like a swastik on like
a pamphlet or something you know but we
didn't have any Jews it was just you
know just local art and somebody [__]
spray painted the dude now what was the
population how many black people out of
the 2000s oh you probably had I would
guess about 1100 brothers and they were
gaining ground quick dude you could even
[__] at night
if you put your ear up to the woods
that's what they would say no no but it
was like any Latinos in that no Market
at that time creeping in oh yeah one kid
how long have you been gone for now one
kid I've been gone for from that town
I've been gone for I left there when I
was probably
maybe 13 I've been gone yeah I'm 36 now
whatever that is 23. 23 years thanks Lee
that's a real Jew even with mushrooms
he could be passed out he'll just pop
his head 23. and I'll go right back to
sleep a little sleep app man he's still
giving estimates
uh they have one Mexican kid this kid uh
Nicholas man the Raper he [__] is
both supposed to write rapper on his
shirt oh oh yeah
they [__] wrote rape and they
expelled them that was the first Mexican
we ever had what is it was your dad
Spanish oh man my dad was Nicaragua so
I'm polish Nicaragua I'm one of the few
you know
there's probably 11 of us out there I
don't know what LSD suppository some
kind of suppositories dude people were
doing yeah dude it was like just do you
know putting these like little they were
kind of uh I don't want to say pink they
were kind of reddish looking little
[__] throwing rainbow treats up yeah
it's not manly enough if it's pink yeah
I mean it was yeah and people was doing
LS these LSD suppositories this dude had
about a I remember he probably had about
400 of them I don't know where he got
them from Germany or somewhere Iceland
or something you know and tell us that
was like they got them from Saturn you
know we never even heard of that Germany
you know we'll [__] do this and
people were doing acid you know uh
whatever it was doing the suppositories
I remember for a while so I like
psychedelics a little bit when I was
younger uh
and what else dude and then but out here
I don't know what happened I just had a
couple of crazy nights and then uh I was
like I'm gonna try something different
man so I just decided I'm gonna stop
partying
so now I got about six months I've been
sober since I'm the last time I walked
out of here I went over to the Improv
and did a set high on mushrooms and they
were flicking the lights on on stage
I still have it on video man I'll put it
out I'll put it out for you uh for for
your legion how old are you now 36 man
I'm an adult it's tough to
say to yourself This is it you know you
have those nights and like we were
saying you had a a spectacular night in
my world like where I came from that's a
spectacular night oh yeah getting in a
cab going for blow uh then the the guy
hooks you up with a chick you [__] the
chick in the cab no he did oh he [__]
her in the cab oh no no this is
craziness now what time did this night
end dude so what happened with that
night was let me revamp it for you so
what happened was I went to a party bro
and I didn't plan on drinking no you're
in New York I'm in New York City yeah
I'm in New York City yep I was doing
comedy I had a sublet there I was just
kind of experiencing the city we talked
once or twice when I was there you know
and I was enjoying it man it was good
and then I got went to a party one night
and afterwards they and they were
drinking at the party and uh
and I just felt uncomfortable dude to be
honest man most of my life I have felt
uncomfortable bro I don't know what it
is like in a lot of environments I just
feel
uncomfortable out of place out of place
yeah yeah yeah you feel that ever oh all
the time what do you mean ever there's
there's more times than I feel in place
like that like that's a weird times but
it's like
my girlfriend and I were just talking
about it because we stayed in on New
Year's Eve yeah but seeing the shots of
Times Square and seeing the shots of the
clubs
maybe I should have done something a
little bit more social but that's that
is not I would I would rather I'd rather
be in a box than in a club see that that
would feel so uncomfortable there like a
New Year's Eve like club like that's not
me at all we don't see in the club today
show you the picture you don't see
people getting [__] molested in the
background and people you know but at
least light a candle or something for
you later you do anything oh well yeah
well we he's gonna Joey's gonna make fun
of me we went away the weekend before we
went to Long Beach as much
[Laughter]
that's amazing this is
so anyway bro I can't even get what it
did that was it you took your girl no
she took me she took me Jesus Christ but
then we just decided to come home
because it was right
because it was rain you know what we're
gonna sit in someone else's apartment on
New Year's Eve down in Long Beach when I
have a nicer apartment up here
oh what the [__] it's a horror show I
tried and I keep it sounds like the
notebook use them by the month it sounds
like the notes
Down syndrome no no this was something
that when he told me I go what now when
he told me I thought they were gonna
leave
Friday night go to a hotel like normal
Americans right yeah wake up in the
morning get a little room service gives
her a stabbing yeah take a walk down
come back smoke a joint eat a star maybe
about six take it to a nice [__]
restaurant six seven o'clock sitting dog
so you're out of there by 9 30 you take
it back to the apartment give it
straight up eat three more stars and
watch some stupid movie I thought that's
what he was doing America I got a call
from him Thursday at lunch time so yeah
yeah we're about to leave I go leave
where Long Beach I almost shot myself in
the [__] head I go this kid can't be
this stupid and then that night I went
to dinner
I had to do a set last week
and
I had two hours to kill
I said tell Mom I don't even make dinner
I'm gonna eat dinner in Hollywood
there's no sense of me coming back yeah
I did a set for Penn State so I had two
hours to kill so I went to chibo
that's one of my favorite places it's a
good place I've never even been there I
see it I don't eat the pizza I don't
even know that [__] I get the salad it's
delicious the the minute whatever salad
and the Big Mama's spaghetti with no
meat
just pasta with sauce and we got cheese
let's give you a small serving it's
always been good I've been eating there
for [__] years wow and that's what I
eat I go there three times a year though
if I'm lucky I got three times to drive
by I got an hour here yeah I got an
audition I plan it I go okay I got an
hour and a half I might as well go to
[__] uh excited yeah
I sit next to a guy I go to the bar and
I see the bartender and he's an old door
guy from The Improv we start chit
chatting two things down for me is a guy
from Edmondson College
and by the way I gotta ask him I had to
ask them what do they teach you up there
in college
and I don't know I'm not sure anymore I
go I hire them because I thought he was
sharper than I was but lately he's been
slipping I don't know what the [__] is
going on
and that was Lee that was Lee I went to
Long Beach Thursday afternoon
for New Year's now I could see it like I
said Friday after all the traffic is
done now here's the best one here's the
best one out of all of them
I call him Thursday night or he calls me
we're talking in the conversation and
also he goes yeah we Airbnb
I go you're not even in a [__] hotel
with like a [__] elliptical that you
can go to the elliptical you've been
home all week with her and now you go
down there for two more [__] nights
with her to do nothing to look at each
other and eat cookies and [__] at a
strange I've watched really bad TV in a
stranger's apartment this was something
that I was like Waters bro I don't know
like [__] squatters when you called
me sadly and told me he was coming back
I wanted to tell him just GPS the car
through the ocean the Santa Monica pier
and take the car right off the [__]
pig because it ain't getting no better
in your life he went away to Long Beach
and every morning when I woke up since
that
today there was a burglary in Long Beach
where the guy shot the burglar he
every day I woke up and then that
morning all I was waiting you were
praying for it to me like Lisa like to
see Lee [__] shot in the head like
Lee got hit by a car coming with a box
of wings they got poor girlfriend on the
thing I don't know what happened the guy
didn't stop for the red light the
saddest part is who the [__] goes to
Long Beach I don't know okay we used to
treat himself to a nice night of chibo
at the bar and now a few years later
he's finally got a girl that wasn't me
that was he was at cheboo that night and
he was thinking about me because the guy
was the medicine I had to ask him what
do they teach you that I didn't teach
you anything well what the [__] do you
have to eat then I'll be honest okay
this was a we we don't have we couldn't
fly anywhere we didn't have enough time
so this is what you chose
but we had we actually had a good time
the [__] aquarium in Queen Mary are
[__] awesome when you're stoned as
[__] but this is what I will I didn't
want to talk to you guys about it
Airbnb the aquarium is
it feels like Squad like it was the
weirdest
experience of my life yeah don't you
touch any animals I get the petting zoo
in here
uh yeah I bought the aquarium yeah but
at the I thought I I thought you were
talking about the apartment for a second
I'm not at the Airbnb dude you [__]
like that's another roommates like
there's roaches in the apartment you
massage another roommates no thank God
they weren't roommates
this guy imagine if there was a roommate
he takes his lady out
no no it was like a horror show yeah I
live I live in a [__] world between
him and my wife I'm not gonna make it to
56.
I'm not gonna make it I just spent four
weeks in that house with my wife wow
it's a torture it's a [__] house
Sahara
I love it with all my heart it's a
torture chamber that's the worst part
like what's the worst part
honestly it'd be 9 30 in the morning at
night and just sitting there not having
a spot because
I don't want to be at the store every
night yeah you know I don't want to be
that guy you don't need to be at the
store every night there's young guys
coming up I know how I felt when I was
coming up and I had [__] to do and
there's some old guy that's coming down
I'm good enough two spots a week I'm
good this week I'm doing Thursday
Flappers if I get out Jiu Jitsu early
Wednesday I'll pop into some place but
you know I got a gig Friday I'm [__]
good I'm not working on nothing or
nothing I'm just putting a dude a couple
bits together finding my new [__]
voice you know yeah
it's like uh
when you travel it breaks the monotony
up a little bit oh yeah and it was I was
home for four [__] weeks and it was
the holidays and one of those weeks the
baby was almost
that's tough babies off of school all
week one week vacation
and it rained three of those days you
know what I'm saying so
she wanted to ride the bicycle that's
like a triple threat so the parents hate
like what doesn't matter is the truth of
the matter is that my I'm a dud
I've always been a dud you know Lee
says that he feels uncomfortable up I
tell you what I where I feel comfortable
I feel comfortable in a bar where the
bartenders
a good-looking woman in 1924. yeah she
still has tits she wears push-up bras
she's got freckles on her tits she's got
a sense of humor the bar seats 20. she
serves some [__] food in there that's
kick ass there's a jukebox there's music
you know what at this age I don't want a
[__] pool table Yeah and I don't want
a dart board I don't want a lot of
movement I never like movement yeah sit
down have a [__] bee and talk to me
if you want to do this if you're gonna
be moving around go somewhere else and
arguments and I can't walk this guy's
throwing a [__] Dawn at me you know I
I I just want to be you know what I'm
saying like that's what I want to do
that's my ideal ball and to be strictly
honest with you since the age of 16 that
was always my Ideal Bar once we started
going out to those discos I've said it
once I've said it before my wife asked
me I'm gonna ride home the other day
from dinner we were listening to Studio
54 on uh Sirius XM and she goes so you
used to go disco dancing are you crazy I
was a kid when that [__] came out yeah I
go when I was in high school
I could put a handful of times I went to
clubs with the studio but I went to
Studio in 84. there was nothing going on
in the studio no more it was a Thursday
night 84. yeah I was going to Club area
like twice I went to like the rooftop
four five six times but I was never a
club guy bro look at me I knew who the
[__] I was I belong to the neighborhood
bar with a bartender named Lila yeah she
had a dog behind a bar the dog slept the
whole [__] time now that's the bar I
grew up in Joe Mary's they had a little
circular biscuit thing like a daily like
a a bakery thing in the middle and it
would have a cover and in the middle it
was ham and cheese sandwiches that's
beautiful so if you want a sandwich you
just went over and got it they had
Stewart sandwiches and next to it was a
uh not don't cook tonight called chicken
though I it was a chicken fill not
Chick-fil-A this is when chicken was
chicken and one of the kids we hung with
was the [__] cook so at the end of
the shift he'd come over to the bar with
a box of chicken
it was and you had a tab and the guy
that ran the place was a loan sharks
you could borrow 300 from on this spot I
still own 8 000. 1980 [__] two
uh you know I I never thought I never
the first time I went to Vegas dog I
knew it wasn't for me yeah I just always
felt very insecure in those places oh I
still do yeah that's how I felt still do
and I always had an excuse in my head on
why I felt insecure when I was younger
it was that I wasn't good looking enough
and I'm a criminal these people are all
nice people these are the environment I
want to hang with and these people don't
want to hang with me yeah then when I
got to a certain age it was I was too
old
and then now I'm like I just feel like I
played out [__] pervert Yeah like I
remember being 25 and seeing like 50
year old guys
thinking why is this [__] guy here
this dude's a perfectly
it's a sweetheart I've seen Lee at a bar
no I could tell he's a gentleman Lee
wants to go to a bar and watch a
football game and have a bucket of wings
and he wants to yell maybe a little bit
he doesn't want nobody close to him
yelling he doesn't want nobody Leo paid
three dollars extra just to you know
what I'm saying yeah it's in the white
section leader wouldn't do good in
studio 54. what's he gonna do have one
drink people gonna try to talk to him I
never liked going to a place where the
music was loud that's where you lose
Uncle Joey yeah if I can't talk to you
the way we're talking another one I'm
lost I'm lost yeah see that's the same
as for me man but I would for some
reason I kept making excuses that made
me like
less than you know so like oh it's my
fault that I don't fit in here instead
of just being like oh this isn't my
environment you know now why didn't you
feel it was your your environment I just
felt like you're older no I felt like uh
you know like these people were rich or
these people were better than me or
these people you know I'm you know I'm
kind of a a bit of a miscreant you know
I grew up on the other side of the
tracks in these people but they don't
know like that's the thing I always
thought because of my my whole thing
comes from like I've always been chubby
and short short you're like a tall
In-Shape good-looking dude I'd look at
you and I think there's nothing wrong in
his life at all like there's no way he's
self-conscious about anything
well I guess we're both wrong man I look
at you and I think this guy's [__]
what environment not at all here with my
main man nephew all around great guy and
hilarious comedian my brother Mr Theo
Vaughn and my little [__] Jewish
friend Mr Lee Syed the Jewish Jingle
Bell baby Johnny hummus wow St Louis
thank you very much for coming out to
the shows this weekend at Helium I had a
[__] blast with you people I really
did uh the food was great twelve dollars
for lunch you know I could move there
and become one of those 600 pound man
they're gonna take me via cargo to
Houston and [__] where I feel every
pothole in my [__] anyway
theovan what up good to be here man
great to be here it's a special occasion
tonight I mean uh yeah it's Theo Von's
one-year sobriety and where else to
spend it here on the church with two
vagabonds [__] THC smokers myself
two [__] hitchhikers on the uh on the
spirit Highway man I love relations bro
July 17th I remember that date forever
because I'll think about you it's
[__] great
well thanks man you've been super
supportive dude whether I you know
whatever I'm doing music or uh I don't
even do music dude
play the flute you want to make noise
make noise Joey's really supportive I
make a phone call my [__] come here
like the Gotti boys
I mean comedy or just chilling you've
always been supportive man so I'm happy
I feel uh I was gonna go to a meeting
tonight but I was like you know what I'm
gonna come here and spend it with you
guys man thank you very much thank you
for having me this is a meeting because
that's what I thought we're gonna get
more from when you get in a meeting
sometimes connected before the show
started
we were talking about the use and abuse
we were doing you know yeah doing in the
scams and the mental
things you go to in just the first year
I remember it took me 90 days to just
[__] realize what was going on and I
would go to bed early I'd force myself
to go to bed early not to have that
withdrawal yeah that nighttime
withdrawal yeah how was it for you
yeah it's true the lady staff the more
you get lonely you know you could feel
the Wolves starting to kind of climb
around inside of you you know that's how
I feel like I feel you know like they
got these dangerous squirrels that kind
of live inside of you and the later you
stay up the more they start you know
kind of peeking their head around you
know looking for drugs and looking for
[__] or something you know and I feel
like if I would go to bed early or you
know shut things down like we'd get a
book or do something calm light a candle
do something that kind of
sets my mind down a little bit that I
would feel better that's what I started
to notice you know so it addiction it's
like a mental thing for you it seems
like it's not like uh I always thought
addiction would be like a more of a
physical thing in town that sounded very
mental it's both yeah it's both it
becomes it starts mental
for me I at the end the last two years
like I've said before dog at five to
eight my body would ache really no
matter what I ate for dinner no matter
what time of a day I had
at five to April my body would start
hurting and I couldn't think
I couldn't think except going to the ATM
that was all that was on my mind yeah
and as soon as that man answered the
phone my heart started beating
I take a [__] and leave you know what
I'm saying yes
when you came in here and told me the
story about New York a year ago yeah I
think that scared you a little bit that
night that made you realize I've always
thought about that story and how you
said it on the podcast yeah
I always thought that
you're very intelligent because you
learned something from that night that
was nothing it could always get worse
yeah it just kind of affected like I
showed up at Opie and Jim over there
with Jim Norton and uh at their show and
I was [__] up you know couldn't even
talk I just had like my mouth open Daryl
strawberries there you know and he
freaking and I'm like Doc good and you
know I'm out there you know looked like
I just been smoking the moon you know
and um and I kept drinking coffees and I
couldn't oh I couldn't close my mouth
also which was weird after a while you
know you can't even close your mouth and
they kept giving me hot coffee
and I was just like damn man I just kept
thinking
you know you wouldn't I wouldn't have
chose to be in this situation if
somebody asked me a year earlier hey you
want to go on Opie and Jim Norton I'd
have been like yeah I'm excited and
they're like yeah do you want to stay up
do cocaine all night the night before
before you go on I'd have been like no
way bro I got to be I gotta be in top
top condition when I get there but here
I was doing that so I'm thinking I must
not be making all of the choices for
myself you know now the drugs are
starting to make some choices how long
have you been doing cocaine at that time
not that long man you know and I just
had a couple of but every time I would
get heavy into it
yeah maybe a couple years but just
sparingly occasionally but when you
would go you would go yeah when I would
go I would go and I started to notice it
was like then it was first it was like
six times a year you know and then it
was then it became like once a month and
then it was becoming uh once a week you
know and so I was like oh this is
escalating man and that [__] escalates
quick dude like one night I left the I
was in my apartment then I was all
[__] up and I used to put on
I got in a box of vests dude somebody
had ordered some vests and I don't know
if it was like a joke or somebody
accidentally got some vests sent to the
wrong person you know but I got a box of
uh of vests you know different types of
you know vest shirts without arms you
know so yeah and different colors and
everything different colors different
styles different patterns everything and
so I would like at night I'd be doing
all this cocaine and putting on these
vests and [__] and kind of you know like
enjoying myself a little bit listen to
some good music you know some Aerosmith
or something you know just just vibing
you know and uh one night I was making a
milkshake uh because I don't like to eat
honestly I like to eat make milkshakes
more often
so I'm making a milkshake and
um and I left a blunt and I got the
blender on right and I went outside of
my apartment door and the door locked
dude right it's like 4 a.m my blender's
going right I'm out there high on
cocaine I got on this vest it's kind of
kind of Tangerine kind of I guess I
don't know what material it was maybe
like Mogadishu or something you know
some [__] kind of fly
so this thing's [__] going dude
there's only like eight units in my
building right so I'm like and then I
guess the machine started smoking the
alarm starts going off right the now
it's 4 a.m dude I got the the things
shorted out the thank God the blender
shorted out but I got the alarm going
off in the building now I'm standing
outside of my apartment wearing boxers
in this [__] orange vest got on sun
shades and then my landlord comes out
and I'm like Jesus Christ you know like
just look at the [__] that's going on
you know and now I gotta tell him I'm
just up going to piss you know like so
just things like that started to get
weird you know I remember I fell asleep
in some lady's bed and just urinated in
her bed and she got angry you know and
she let me sleep over and I told usually
I tell people before I sleep over that I
went to bed once in a while you know so
but anyway man it was uh
yeah just just wild stuff started to
happen you know be over at people's
houses
you know just
it's getting late you know you're
touching some girl's crotch outside of
an apartment building over there and you
know Studio City or out near the airport
you're like what the [__] am I doing you
know it's not bad but I'm you know I did
this already I'm still doing this you
know so that was some of the issues that
I started to notice some of the patterns
you know
it's uh
it's very sad when you look back at the
stupid [__] you did that's true it
starts up
the talk we were having before the
podcast started is it always starts off
recreational yeah listen man for me that
way for me in L.A what's a good plan for
me in L.A
well I would get a call in 99
2002 dog
you know I would get that call on Monday
and they'd say you have spots Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday in the old days you
called on Monday and Tuesday morning
they called you a Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday she wouldn't give you Friday
Saturday till Friday it [__] Duke oh
she would bury you till Friday you keep
calling and you go I don't know
sometimes they be there Thursday but
anyway that's not what we're talking
about here I would you look at the week
and you see what you got and you planned
I would plan my because for me the best
time I ever had in L.A was going to the
store
drinking a cocktail and drinking sodas
before I went on stage yeah that's right
it's like being a straight gay guy bro
he's my little brother I gotta accept
him what am I going to do thank you I
appreciate it
he's a beautiful and one of my 70
favorite people right there Lisa yeah
the top 70 people in People magazine
that's your favorite at least I had some
bad [__] my favorite 70 people
dead or alive dude I don't think I know
70 people yeah you do every [__] body
who dies they always make 250 Mass cards
for you did you know that yeah really
yeah because everybody on the average
knows 250 [__] people that's why in
business you have to be nice to
everybody wow everybody knows 250 people
at least not Twitter not Facebook right
you're you've been in contact with 250
people if you die by the age of 50
between classmates high school mates
College mates people at your job over 25
30 [__] years that's the average a
lot of people don't know that you learn
that when you buy telemarketing in the
70s that book helped me in more ways
than one
telemarketing if you want to sell you
got that's what you [__] sell yeah
selling Generations let's say you sell
[__] vacuums and you're serious
amount
what you hope is
that Lee becomes your Goomba and Lee's
son buys your vacuums Lee's daughter
buys your vacuums Lee's wife you know is
what you want fifth generation on them
cubes that's what you do that's what a
good [__] salesman does you know
that's so weird you're at the Chris
thing you're doing everything yeah dude
I'll tell you that's my sister used to
be a exotic dancer right she used to be
in the [__] where uh Louisiana's kind
of certain areas you know tough living
yeah it's a tough area it's best out
there and actually learned to dance and
I remember this while bro she learned to
dance in a
like it was like a trailer right like it
was like a you know exotic place it was
a trailer but the stage wasn't very high
and the stage was too high in the
trailer
so this the dancers had to crouch and
strip at the end dance at the same time
dude so if you were over like five four
you had to like Duck and look sexy and
that's hard to do man think about that
I've never had to think about that
because I'd be fine in that trailer yeah
you'd be good bro oh you beat a [__]
you beat a dessert dancer bro they bring
you out with the [__] with the creme
brulee man
although I can Lee would take the stage
like a [__] Thanksgiving how many how
many creme brulees do you think Lee
would dance so that [__] came
out every hour on the hour at least
eight at least eight an hour I would
sell eight every 15 minutes but there's
only so many people in the building but
this is a very small club now let me ask
you this yeah but if I come to this club
and to see me they like dessert I love
dancing she was probably out there for I
guess about eight years eight years in
the trailer
oh no she just started there she then
she went into uh buildings that were
zoned correctly and everything you know
she could stretch out you know did you
get mad at all those years were you
upset with her let me think man we
weren't really close growing up I mean
always I actually older than you were
younger than younger than me okay yeah
so you were upset I mean I was uh
well the crazy part was honestly we look
alike so I would see dudes sometimes
looking at me like weirdly like around
when I was out at lunch and [__] you
know and they were like do I know you go
do that
good
yeah
hilarious but uh but so I guess that if
we wouldn't have looked alike it might
have it might have not been so wild to
me but you know what dude she didn't
have you know she was missing some
elements growing up and you know I
respect I respect any women if they're
out there in those type of environments
because that's a hard environment and
that you know
because otherwise if you're not doing
that what uh what are you doing then you
know
if you're at that invite if you're at
that doorstep Where You Are
you know where you're looking for an
occupation but you're if you're not
doing that you're probably up to some
dark art
you know
sorry about that
[Music]
I hear music yeah that's Joey's ringtone
it's like Elvis for the holidays
you want some [__] Memphis email list
bro
I don't [__] know what kind of did
you go to that strip club in in the
trailer I mean I'd been I mean I'd been
over there before but I didn't you know
I wouldn't go there with my sister well
no I would hope not but I can't even
imagine like is it just like a
construction trailer that they just put
a little stage in and a couple folding
chairs I mean I don't think that they
had you know a lot I don't know if
they're what their long-term business
model was you know I mean I'll say that
but they you know it was good it was a
Small Town Place you know and people
were enjoying themselves and uh
but yeah I mean I mean I love my sister
she's the best you know I mean I would
I mean she's a [__] G man she's a
[__] G you know she's she's real as
they get it's crazy because well what
were we talking about what were we
talking about
squatting the trailer but even got into
this conversation no no it's just weird
that did she ever go to a big city and
dance or did she keeps it like
Shreveport I mean I think she you know
nothing real crazy I don't think I mean
we weren't that close at a lot of that
she's married now no she's not single
still single regular mingle ready to
mingle cool check though kids no kids
look she kept it together man yeah
that's what I'm saying look
listen you're 22 right you're 22. you
got nothing going on I mean what are
your [__] options you're gonna go
work at a vet yeah or a daycare for
eight dollars an hour or whatever
I say young girl I mean you know and I
have a daughter I would feel if she came
to me and said like I'm gonna go to
[__] College
but I got an answer I'm gonna go strip
for five years for four years
four years I could have been in college
I'm gonna go strip but you're not that
intelligent to grasp it at that time
right girls that go into that go into
that and I'm not talking on that line
here because they were missing something
yeah for the first time somebody paid
attention to him yeah so oh yeah she was
abused she had like this this violent
kind of black boyfriend she dated and
that abused and I think that's what got
her into it you know you know it's just
uh you don't give a [__] about yourself
but think about it with you
with what you know now yeah the
knowledge you have now if you're a
[__] an 18 year old chick your tits
were hot you got a nice little ass all
these guys are torturing you all the
time they're [__] broke
you know I mean yeah as a woman you go
you know what I wasn't raised to do this
yeah but it's 2 000 [__] 17. yeah I'm
gonna go to Subway and be surrounded by
stiffs or some you know dudes jerking
off over there anyway so they caught two
dudes jerking off by our Subway at least
yeah there was something about it I
think it was just
I don't know it could have been the air
freshener or something literally the
subway [__] made you feel it wrecked
but I think they had one of those
lavender air things in there but I'm not
making fun of Subway employees I always
not believe that the [__] my biggest
fear is when you walk into Subway like
who I thought I was gonna turn out to be
honest to God
and I didn't want this if you ever going
to Subway and everybody's 22 but then
there's one guy that's 50 with a
ponytail that was you and he's he's got
an earring and he's still he's still
cool like he's still fighting the
[__] cool it don't matter that he
lives in an apartment where they dudes
and whatever he got home the other night
they were listening to Aqualung and it
doesn't matter what matters is that he
went to see Guns and Roses you know uh
two weeks ago right this is what's going
on he's living his life yeah he's living
his life but he didn't really look at
the other part of your life he didn't
look at that ladder when life moves
[__] fast and you're still talking
about some [__] band yeah with
everybody else your age is growing up is
growing the [__] up you know it's it's
kind of a weird I was always scared to
be that guy that petrified mainly well I
mean don't you think it would take like
a very specific kind of person to be be
like be a stripper not get affected by
it because you're talking like oh it'd
be great who are the [__] 10 right
the percentages two out of ten if you
and make an educated guess yeah I went
to a strip club a year ago nine months
ago I get bored I'm like any other
[__] guy yeah I'm home one night it's
10 15 everybody's [__] sleeping yeah
everybody's asleep in my house at 10 15.
like out yeah I can't even [__] Pudge
somebody you know I I tried to wake my
wife up to give me the 10 the pen the
iTunes so I could order the [__]
phone she told me to go [__] myself you
know what I'm saying everybody's out in
my [__] house at [__] 10 15. yeah
it's like oh let me go to Yum Yum Donuts
then you're a fat [__] you just sit in a
donut stand waiting for them by yourself
yeah I said [__] it they got a lot of
Home other transvestites if you stay on
Colfax and go up to like Victory and
make a left there's a strip club
you know you're just sitting there
looking at [__] and tits and it's
phenomenal I'm not gonna say that yeah I
didn't like it though it was dirty yeah
first off the strip club is always empty
yeah I mean you can't believe
how empty it is like bone dry like this
four [__] guys sitting there drinking
water because it's nude yeah water like
they're showing they're showing photos
of people that were in there earlier in
the day yeah
there's four people in here and like you
know you talk to different girls there
was one girl I talked to that her
boyfriend comes to comedy shows she
comes with them all the time oh wow and
there was another girl that her
boyfriend was a [__] fan of the
podcast and and uh you know oh you know
you have all these girls that are in
there that don't talk to you yeah and I
looked at them and I'm like look at that
girl she's 18. there was one girl I was
20.
you know I give her the whole bank
account yeah you know you look at her
and go you you give her the whole bank
account like listen just come home with
me go get your clothes I'm gonna throw
my wife out when we get home yeah I'm
sure and for some dudes they would do
that and then you have the girls with a
42 man yeah they're out there banging it
they're eating grapefruit juice and
jumping and yeah [__] uh you know and
you got to give them a heart like you
sit there and go I know what she's going
through yeah I don't want to pick the 20
year old because she's gonna feel bad
but if I picked a 20 year old right the
20 year old will glob all over you and
suck your sperm she doesn't know if
there's HIV out there and chlamydia of
the mouth and [__] yeah she's still
thinking she could you know well the 40
year old gives you hand wipes because
she knows you're going to finger her and
she don't want the leftover salt from
the pretzel you had two hours earlier
it's just really weird bro when you uh
deal with when they become a
professional yeah like have you ever
bumped into a professional stripper yeah
it's like staying at comedy for a
certain period of time it's like there's
a certain day certain day when you're
like you realize oh oh I know what
you're doing all right
and when you deal with a professional
stripper you go in there dog should take
you into the first room first she'll
give you a couple whips on her monkey
yeah
this will take you upstairs banging out
for the small four bills and that's
where she becomes a nun yeah and you're
like what the [__] happened she sold you
yeah Shane is tripping no more she's a
sales woman now yeah you want to [__]
suck that's 2 000 for this [__] piece
of ass yeah you want to look at me two
thousand [__] two thousand they
look at you when they're gonna squeeze
you bro what you want to smell my
[__] you're not gonna eat a yogurt at
the same time 11 guys no more five
they're gonna [__] [__] six guys for
a thousand dollars yeah and make 12 000
a week two thousand dollars so I've even
thought I've thought about it if you pay
whatever that is two thousand five
hundred that's not the whole night
that's like one one round I guess well
you can negotiate whatever the [__] you
want okay thank god dude what about
[__] just somebody regular and
tipping them after is that crazy you
think like if it's just a girl you met
they get insulted yeah I could see you
telling the girl listen man I'm gonna go
out of town on Thursday I didn't know
this was gonna happen I had a great time
can you get to allows them leave it
there for you if you do your toes yeah
nails and get yourself lunch with your
girlfriend you know yeah that's the way
to do it it's how you [__] do it you
know it's not making them feel like a
[__] hooker yeah but but you can't
[__] yeah you know it's like right now
Harvey Weinstein's getting in trouble
for all this [__] and and yeah he's a
pig
but you gotta admit there's a there's a
thousand guys out there I used to date a
girl bro that was a stripper and after a
year or two I accepted what she did
and I used to just talk to her sometimes
and by talking to her it really showed
me how pathetic men were because not
even in my deepest darkest moment would
I do something like that yeah you know
yeah I like [__] getting your dick
sucked everybody does everybody likes to
bump into somebody with an alien monkey
yeah have a good time [__] look out
on somebody's car seat especially as a
comedian but to walk into a strip club
right out
and this is what they do every week this
is their freak this is and I tell people
all the time that you're married so you
have these boundaries yeah and then you
present yourself with personal
boundaries
and you go you know what I got a wife I
got a kid I got a daughter I gotta go
home now four [__] hours my wife
don't bang me like she used to she don't
let me come in the hand no more all
those days are done yeah
[Music]
foreign